[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we'll be discussing a
moment in this series
when harry and the horcrux inside of him
face possible
destruction after the chamber of secrets
a lot of fans were left asking
themselves
why wasn't the horcrux inside of harry
destroyed after he was bitten by the
basilisk
this is a very reasonable question for
people to ask especially as
basilisks venom is one of the confirmed
known ways
to destroy a horcrux if basilisk's venom
destroys horcruxes and harry has a
horcrux inside of him
then why wasn't it destroyed i made a
very old
and brief video on this in the past but
a lot of people have been asking me this
question lately
so i thought i'd add some information
and do a better job of it
as we know in the chamber of secrets
harry is in possession of tom riddle's
diary the same diary that harry uses to
source information
about the fabled chamber when he finally
finds the entrance to the chamber
he speaks parcel tongue and opens it up
then he's faced with a couple of things
first a memory of tom riddle preserved
by the diary
and next a gigantic basilisk aka
the serpent of slytherin a creature
placed there by salazar slitherin
himself
one of the four founders of hogwarts the
basilisk was originally placed there to
rid the school of all muggleborns
and could only be controlled by the
rightful heir of slytherin
who we know to be tom middle it's worth
mentioning
that even though harry could speak to
the basilisk with parcel tongue
he had no control over it throughout the
chamber of secrets we see hogwarts
students drop off like flies
this is because the basilisk is on the
loose when victims were found they were
most commonly in a petrified state
similar to the victims of medusa when
the basilisk
looks at you directly it suggested that
it would kill you instantly
however if you look at the basilisk
indirectly it only petrifies you
when harry becomes aware of the
capabilities of the basilisks
gaze he's more disoriented than ever and
simply runs away from it
with no real plan fortunately forks
dumbledore's phoenix
intervenes and claws the basilisk's eyes
out this
blinds the basilisk and makes things
much easier for harry
however just because the basilisk is no
longer able to see
it certainly doesn't suddenly mean that
it isn't lethal
it's still a giant serpentine creature
with sharp teeth and a killer instinct
it can hurt harry in other ways however
knowing that the basilisk is blind
gives harry just enough confidence to
begin fighting back
after lots of running around aimlessly
harry is unfathomably lucky once again
as he is able to retrieve the sword of
gryffindor from the sorting hat
it is said that a true worthy gryffindor
is capable of pulling the sword from the
hat
and harry fits this criteria beautifully
after some back and forth with the
basilisk
harry lures it up to the top of the
statue of slytherin
where he slashes ferociously when the
basilisk lunges at harry for the first
time
harry is knocked over but when the
basilisk goes in for a second lunge
her face is met with the sword of
gryffindor as harry stabs her through
the roof of the mouth
this effectively puts an end to the
basilisk but
harry doesn't escape unscathed as one of
the basilisks
fangs pierced his arm this is where fans
have historically been a bit confused
now we know basilisks fangs quite well
in the books and films
and that's because they're capable of
destroying horcruxes or at least
the venom inside of them is harry even
later uses the sword of gryffindor
to destroy several of the other
horcruxes because it was imbued with the
basilisks venom
so if harry has a horcrux inside of him
and he was inflicted
with basilisk's venom why was the
horcrux still intact
when harry yanked the fang out of his
arm he knew that he'd been wounded by
the venom
and felt the poison spreading however
fortunately for harry
he's a very lucky boy once again as
fawkes was still present
and saved harry's life just in time with
his tears
the tears of a phoenix are said to
possess immense healing capabilities
including but not limited to healing
wounds from those who have been
inflicted
with basilisks venom in fact the tears
are so powerful
that they can even revive people who are
at the brink of death as harry was
so harry's life was saved but in almost
all of the cases of the other horcruxes
they were destroyed as soon as they made
contact with basilisk's venom
so how did it remain inside of harry
unscathed
here's the thing we need to remember in
order for horcrux to be destroyed
the container itself needs to be
destroyed beyond magical repair
and in this case harry was the container
jk rowling has stated herself
that because harry was technically not
beyond repair the horcrux
remained safe in order for the basilisks
venom
to have been successful in penetrating
the horcrux
harry would have needed to die but forks
of course saved the day
and possibly the wizarding world and
that's it for this video
i hope you learned something if you
enjoyed it please be sure to like the
video
and subscribe to support the channel
until next time
you're a wizard harry
[Music]
you